you know I thought about it the other
day me coming here and also so it was
getting married I suppose I thought
about sort of my life and and what I've
done and I realized that all the stuff
that I've always been doing is producing
sort of being a generalist I suppose not
good at particular anything but sort of
knowing a little bit about a lot of
things and then producing some sort of
content and one of the first things I
ever did which is partly the reason I
got to start that agency or we started
that agency is we had a new the
newspaper i mentioned earlier and they
wanted to sell more ads and so it was it
was a business-to-business kind of
assignment and you know they went around
when they're kind of demographic pie
charts about how f want their readers
were and stuff like that which was
pretty boring and so what our idea was
we went to to London is when I went
Chris at when I'm at David Abbott he
went to London we met some of the most
sort of prestigious advertising people
in the world so I most accomplished
people and we asked them about print
advertising and they're all old
copyrighted so they loved it and they
grew up with it so they were all talking
about how print was important the
written word and love over and we made
this magazine so as a 52-page magazine
about about print advertising so all of
a sudden the newspaper instead of coming
with their pie charts they had this
beautifully produced magazine that they
could go to only advertising agencies
and all the advertisers and the media
buyers and say we went to London and we
met David Abbott and this is what he has
to say and here's a magazine and of
course they were the coolest newspaper
in the world everybody loved it and all
the creatives wanted to have an ad in
this newspaper so I think and I think
that's a good example of not intrusive
media you know you read it or you don't
and I picked it up I read it a couple of
a couple weeks ago and it's actually
like pretty good you know even 10 years
after its
has a right to exist
yeah there's many reasons but I'm my
main reason for backing on I mean I
guess intrusive is a word with you know
sort of double meaning I wouldn't
necessarily mind having well probably
would actually um I mean the sound thing
is interesting I am I don't think it's
pretty clear effective I think at the
end of the day I think I mean a brand is
what you tell you know a brand is what
people say when you left the room that's
what a branded and so what do you want
you know that you're kind if you come to
me and you're a client and you say you
know it's like how the big thing and
yells in your year and you wake up and
you know I would probably be like would
you want to be that guy would you want
to like wake me up with a megaphone I
and so I don't think it's peculiar it's
like it's like being a good friend or
being a good i mean the best thing you
can do as a person I suppose is like
imagine if i said to you when we leave
us at least you should check this band
out or you should read this magazine or
you should go to this a new store on the
corner and you go and you go okay great
and you go down or you buy this CD or
you read the book and you love it and
you you've discovered a new you know a
new author or a new brand or a new store
or a new song or new group you'll be
like Frederick using a pretty good Rigga
guy like I love this song and bringing
your friends and I was something I've
given you something that and if I could
do that without you feeling like I
wanted something from you you you start
trusting me you know you're my opinion
would matter and things you know next
time I called you up and I asked you to
you know you know about another tip you
about another song you'd probably listen
so as a company you probably you know
whatever it is you do you want to be the
authority on that you want to be the guy
or the girl that that you know that is
the authority on on flying airplanes or
you know being the carrier of wireless
service and stuff like that and I think
that that's responsibility that you have
to take serious and I think a lot of
companies don't
and that's that's interesting too
you